pour bienvenue dans point de vue et à la
une cet après-midi la catalogne
indépendante met sous tutelle c'est le
coup de théâtre de l'après midi
le parlement catalan a déclaré
l'indépendance et le sénat espagnol a
aussitôt déclenché l'article 155
on ira à barcelone prendre les premières
réactions
on s'intéressera aussi à la guyane
département plus que français même si le
chef de l'état
il y est en ce moment très contestée
contester le glyphosate l'est assurément
80% même plus des français sont contre
ce sondage au dock sata dessous pour le
figaro mais est-ce qu'ils sont bien
informés des bas dans cette émission et
focus juste après après notamment une
question et si la plus grande menace
contre la droite ne s'appelait pas
laurent wauquiez on attend d'ailleurs la
réponse sur ce sujet de carl meeus
journaliste au figaro magazine et grand
spécialiste de la droite française dans
toutes ses chapelles dont toutes ces
querelles byzantines à la une par
ailleurs du figaro magazine ce week end
un dossier passionnant sur le
réchauffement climatique et son impact
sur la france dans 40 ans les sondages
les réseaux c'est la spécialité de
véronique rixe août
bonjour rigoriste consulting eugénie
bastié nous fait l'amitié d'être là ce
soir
elle a du mérite parce qu'elle a
beaucoup de travail d'autant plus qu'un
jour n'est pas coutume on n'abordera pas
son sujet phare le féminisme et ses
excès mais consolez vous il y a quand
même toujours son livre qui est en vente
absolument indispensable d'ailleurs
adieu mademoiselle la défaite des femmes
jean baptiste émergents journaliste au
service réseaux sociaux du figaro
magazine est également avec nous et il
nous donnera à vos questions vous que
vous nous posez sur la page facebook du
figaro mais également sur le player du
figaro.fr c'est-à-dire l'écran dans
lequel vous voyez cette émission on va
donc chose premier chose du tout de
suite allé à barcelone en parlait hier
soir on en parlait hier soir un carrelet
depuis jeudi
président de la généralité de catalogne
n'avait fait aucun geste et bien on a
compris puisque la crise s'est accentuée
cet après midi entre madrid et barcelone
à 15h28 le parlement de catalogne a voté
à 70 voix pour l'indépendance et une
demi heure plus tard le sénat à madrid a
voté par 214 voix contre 47
la mise sous tutelle de la région va à
barcelone où se trouve
tanguy barque berthomé envoyé spécial du
figaro au milieu des manifestants dépend
dentiste bonjour tanguy que se
passe-t-il actuellement qu'elle est
quelle est l'ambiance là où vous êtes
clé l'ambiance est un petit peu à
l'image de ce qu'il fait toujours passer
en catalogue jusque là c'est à dire
étonnamment calme et tous ces
manifestations ne sont que
exceptionnellement marqué par la
violence
et aujourd'hui ça a été un petit peu à
l'image du reste c'est à dire foule
assez dense où la fée nombreux mais
étonnamment disciplinés on prête le dire
jean king
tanguy est ce que là les manifestants on
imagine les indépendantistes qui sont là
où vous êtes sont prêts à en découdre
centre est allé jusqu'au bout avec avec
madrid parce que du côté de madrid on
l'a compris on ira jusqu'au bout et on
va à la mise sous tutelle
oui là la détermination des manifestants
sur des manifestants en tout cas ceux
qui sont aujourd'hui réunies autour du
parlement sur aucun doute ils sont
décidés à obtenir l'indépendance
tétreault elle est l etat qui dès les
fêtes
elle a été votée maintenant je ne crois
pas que le terme ont des coudreaux soit
exact puisque en même temps touché ainsi
énormément
que ce soit dans la rue vous aussi les
associations et d'hommes politiques pour
aller battre pour rester dans la
violence absolue jusqu'à calais par dans
quelle est la suite des événements
à à barcelone maintenant c'est trop
difficile à savoir l' ambiance
extrêmement qu'est ce qu'il ya autour du
parc sont réunis les dizaines de
milliers de personnes savoir
l'indépendance la suite du film dont il
est en train de se dérouler et
complètement inconnu on ignore
totalement ce qui va se passer à
certains nombre de manifestants
s'attendait effectivement à ce que
madrid real madrid envoie éventuellement
sortir les policiers qui pourrait
effectivement changé l'ambiance est
donnée les affrontements mais pour
l'instant personne ne fait rien juste
une dernière question tanguy qu'est ce
qu'ils sont les manifestants
actuellement est ce que ce sont ses
membres des des associations civiles qui
se sont beaucoup beaucoup mobilisé pour
cette indépendance est ce que c'est
l'extrême gauche qui radical
indépendantiste est extrêmement
hétéroclites il ya des gens qui sont
plus prosaïques fatto gauche mais on
croise aussi beaucoup de gens qui
ressemblent à des veuves ira une
prosodie convenable sans trop droit il
ya tous les bases on va de son très très
jeunes des étudiants jusqu'à des gens
qui sont bien retraités c'est
extrêmement divers et ça reflète
totalement le l'imprégnation si vous
voulez le lit des indépendantistes au
sein de la population
mais ça ça montre aussi le clivage qu'il
ya au sein de ceux de ce mouvement
indépendantiste puisque tous ces gens
n'ont évidemment pas du tout la même
idée de ce que pourrait être une capable
de prendre
merci beaucoup tanguy pour toutes ces
précisions et puis votre partage est à
lire sur lefigaro.fr et bien sûr dans
les colonnes du figaro de ce samedi il y
a déjà un reportage que vous avez fait
dans les colonnes du figaro de ce
vendredi et qui est également sur le
figaro.fr merci beaucoup et puis on
continue de suivre ces événements avec
vous
karl j'ai envie de vous poser une
question on voit ça nous vu de france
ils sont pas poussées catalan ils sont
en train de le devenir
oui parce que on entend bien ce que nous
a dit tanguy berthemet ce qu'aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs car laisse pleinement a
insisté en disant qu'ils n'en maîtrise
pas ce que l'ambiance est très calme et
dans le sens où ils disent voilà c'est
pacifique
on ne veut pas de violence puis demande
a insisté aussi là dessus en disant on y
va de manière pacifique et tout c'est
juste impossible que ça se compte que ça
continue sur cette ambiance là pourquoi
parce que à madrid et vous l'avez dit si
l'on décidé de l'application de
l'article 155 ça veut dire la
destitution du président de l'assemblée
de catalogne
voilà donc appartement eux mêmes déclaré
l'abondance il va pas accepter d'être
destitué ça veut dire également la mise
sous tutelle de toute l'administration
catalan des de la police catalane de
l'ensemble de l'administration j'imagine
mal qui se laisse être mis sous tutelle
assez facilement donc la réalité c'est
qu'on voit bien qu'on va aller vers un
affrontement et que ça va être tout sauf
pacifique
vous êtes séduits par cette ambiance
pacifique tout à la célébration de
l'identité régionale catalane
maïté moi je suis quelqu'un je pense que
ça va se terminer
mal et on à faire un retour tant attendu
du tragique et de l'histoire est le
propre de la tragédie ce qui a pas de
bonne solution or là on voit que dans ce
conflit ce conflit entre volonté il va
pas y avoir de bonnes solutions puisque
ça va ça va forcément se terminer mal
puisque madrid va employer le
a le monopole de la force légitime et il
va envoyer évidemment pour faire
respecter sa volonté va envoyer des
soldats évidemment aimé on je
m'interroge quand même sur la voilà sur
le jusqu'au boutisme du motoriste des
autorités catalanes puisque là on a
quand même 70 députés décident de
l'indépendance d'une région sachant que
les députés de l'opposition ont quitté
l'hémicycle qui n'étaient pas présents
pendant le vote donc 70 députés sur 135
c'est une majorité de 5
sachant qu'une partie des députés de
l'opposition n'étaient pas présents donc
c'est quand même très très très court
sachant que leurs enfants un homme lui
même il n'y avait il y avait 2 millions
participants s'étaient pas contrôler et
c'est donc c'est quand même très faible
comme la légitimité pour avoir une maman
pour faire l'indépendance voire une
légitimité très forte et ses difficultés
elle est pas là écoutez vous avez
conscience que vous parlez exactement
comme olivier duhamel
je pensais pas que vous étiez soit un
bon gars disent il s'exprimait hier on
écoute et on écoute juste avant mariano
rajoy le président du gouvernement
espagnol pp démarchage de riches que les
autorités européennes ont adopté
l'achigan tâche des fichiers aux niches
la primaire a procédé la fraîcheur et le
président de la generalitat de catalunya
d'elbit présidente et hydrologiques
intégral et le concept de google alors
voilà il on va écouter maintenant
olivier duhamel qui était pas votre
place à celle de karl
mais il parlait exactement comme vous
c'était hier donc d'un point de vue on
écoute faut bien que ce référendum est
assez largement un échec parce que il ya
quand même 60 % des catalans qui n'ont
pas dit oui à l'indépendance qui ne sont
pas allés voter ou qui ont tous sont
allés voter non comme il ya 80% des
catalans qui soutenait l'idée d'un
référendum et le référendum 90% des
personnes ont dit oui à l'indépendance
je répète peut-être mais ya 60% des
catalans qui ne sont pas allés voter
pour l'indépendance ce qui est dans un
contexte confrontation avec le pouvoir
central le cycle l'idée de
l'indépendance est aujourd'hui en
catalogue minorité l'avantagent du
présentateur secure prendre la parole
il ya quand même une chose c'est que
pourquoi si on calcule y avait 10
personnes qui ont dit non à
l'indépendance il ya 135 députés y en a
70 qui ont qui ont convoité
pour l'indépendance si les autres
étaient restées là on n'est pas sûr que
l'indépendance aura été votée cet
après-midi parlement de catalogne
oui mais parce qu'ils étaient en
désinformation est le principe même de
la beauté au sein du parlement donc et
ses partenaires lors des 50 sur le 6 mai
c'est le principe du camp vous boycotter
une élection vous estimez que cette
élection n'est pas juste et que
et un référendum et que les trucs et on
n'y participant pas vous des actes et la
légitimité de ceux de convenir de ce
vote
mais aujourd'hui la question qu'on se
pose
elle est plus d'être pour ou contre
l'indépendance et n'est même plus le
sujet le sujet c'est la légalité du
processus est aujourd'hui dans un
processus d'insurrection insurrectionnel
et quasiment révolution c'est pas dans
ces gars c'est pas l'ambiance qui est
mort seul pour le moment mais pour le
moment mais cela ne peut terminer que ça
ne peut se terminer que par la violence
puisqu'une par le droit pour le moment
il ya un blocage total et que le droit
du côté de madrid
burning résulte la majorité des français
selon un précédent sondage aux hawks a
été opposée à l'indépendance de la
catalogne
est-ce que c'est toujours le cas si on
regarde pas de sondages plus récents je
peux vous regardez ce qui se dit sur les
réseaux et les réseaux sépare
représentatif c'est certainement
significatif ne s'est pas représentatif
et on s'intéresse et continuer à poser
vos gains non mais c'est significatif
par le volume et par la réalité de
l'expression mais ça tous les français
ne s'exprime pas sur les réseaux ce qui
est certain c'est que comme jenny alpha
l'exprimer on a un sujet en fait qu'on
retrouve sur les réseaux qui est la
légitimité face à la légalité et ce
sujet là on voit bien que c'est
compliqué à voir si on regarde le
mouvement de balancier qui a eu sur les
réseaux pas que en france d'ailleurs
mais la france suisse ce mouvement là
le dimanche du référendum ce n'était pas
un soutien pour les indépendantistes
loin de là mais par contre c'était une
grosse colère contre la façon dont le
gouvernement espagnol avait réagi avec
entre voilà la répression est entre
autres je passe ou souvenez mais l'image
d'une femme d'un certain âge qui était
couverte de sang qui avait été beaucoup
partagé et qui avait fait qu en fait
l'expression toute la journée a été très
négative
après il ya eu un mouvement de balancier
dans l'autre sens ce qui était plutôt en
faveur d autoritaire on sent que c'est
quand même compliqué et que les prises
de parole des autorités catalanes était
quand même complexe et qu'on avait du
mal à comprendre leur logique donc
c'était voilà donc toujours pas de
soutien des indépendantistes et là où
c'est compliqué certes dans la rue en
entend pas mais on peut dire que
peut-être les réseaux c'est un prémisse
de la rue est bien là ça devient
compliqué parce que les deux extrêmes
s'exprime beaucoup on va polarisation
une polarisation forte partout en
auvergne en faveur des deux des
prophéties sombre de cale de génie en
tout cas on voit que c'est très très
excessifs c'est très très fort on a
quand même un million cent messages
depuis ce matin donc on peut pas dire de
nouveau pourtant c'est très important
c'est sur toute l'europe
bien sûr on parle plutôt en espagne mais
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de messages en
angleterre aussi avec toujours un
parallèle locale donc là c'est un sujet
sur l'ecosse mais on voit qu'il ya
quelque chose qui monte et il n'y a pas
de prise de parole de l'europe
et ça on entend beaucoup ça leur réseau
ou andy barr et finalement que va faire
le rabat justement vous avez là la
réponse d'arlette sur facebook car la
dart 1 kg lui l'europe et pour l'espagne
et non pas pour une région qui se
déclarent indépendante est effectivement
donald tusk dit tout à l'heure donc
juste après la le vote par le sénat du
déclenchement du vote de l'article 155
l'espagne est notre seule interlocutrice
l'espagne donc l'europe défend
l'intégrité territoriale
oui on a souvent dit que l'europe encore
été constante sur l'accueil encourager
non sur nick love encourager les
régionalismes justement pour fragiliser
les états nations on a la preuve de la
verse et on voit quand même que le
l'europe tient tient aux états nations
ne serait ce que parce que ce sont des
acteurs stable qui permettent de
d'avoir un minimum de discussion et
d'organisation et je crois que oui le
reproche qu'on fait à l'europe
d'encourager le régionalisme dans le cas
de catalogne a complètement injustifiée
puisque depuis le début union européenne
dit soin de soi et neutre soit à prendre
prend position en faveur de l'espagne et
mme emmanuel macron lui-même qui est un
européiste convaincu a pris position en
faveur de madrid carles macron passagers
partagez cet avis est un homme s'est
converti au souverainisme je reconnais
application ce que disait pascal erreur
en deçà des pyrénées vérité au dollar
parce que non mais est ce que le flamand
card mais lui je pense que la flandre
les flamands et espagne oui c'est
exactement
non mais c'est intéressant de voir la
réaction de tous les leaders européens
face à cette crise pourquoi d'abord
parce que ils sont tous à la tête
d'états qui sont concernés par le plus
ou moins par ce sujet là
l'angleterre on l'a rappelé avec les
causes l'italie avec la ligue du nord
on rappelle d'ailleurs qu'il ya une
émission qui vous pouvez retrouver sur
lefigaro.fr interactions de magazines
des correspondants du figaro qui est
consacré à la montée des régionalismes
le pays basque également enfin voilà
donc chacun étant concernés ils se sont
tous solidariser avec l'espagne en dix
ans et c'est l'état c'est le garde un
états unis et ce qui est intéressant ce
que rappelait jean yves est laissé les
structures de l'europe qui elle-même
également sont sur cette ligne parce que
au fond quand donald hess dit ça ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que les
conséquences d'une catalogne
indépendante c'est qu'elle sort de
l'union européenne et donc elle n'est
plus dans l'euro et n'a plus
d'interlocuteur
parce que là en ce moment tout le monde
a l'air de diass fanfare pas nous mais
une grande partie de gens d'ici
formidable il se passe quelque chose à
madre à barcelone on voit les gens
disent que c'est quand même il s'est
quand même plus plus plus enlevées plus
il se passe plus de choses que je sais
les républicains sont plus intéressants
tous les cas à suivre oui alors je sais
pas si on peut les comparer au kenya au
coeur le problème c'est le lendemain
c'est qu'est ce qui va se passer parce
que là c'est
c'est presque un saut dans le vide les
etats unis soutiennent d'ailleurs
également l'unité de l'espagne pas de
pas de soutien à la sécession
sylvie nous dit sur facebook
les catalans nous sommes pacifiques si
exemple la force ce sera à la cause de
l'europe qui n'intervient pas oui mais
sylvie ajoute la fota rajoy qui n'a pas
autorisé un référendum légal le résultat
aurait été nommé on aurait gagné du
temps c'est un peu ça c'est quand même
mon programme et ça c'est l'erreur de
lardi mme séverine finition le début il
ya quand même un oui mais quelque chose
d'intéressant dans cette émergence des
régionalismes qui doit nous interroger
c'est pourquoi de plus en plus la région
devient une identité de substitution
face ajustements à la fragilisation des
états nations et une mondialisation
extrême qui fait que finalement les gens
se sentent un peu perdus il ya une
espèce de la fois individualisme et
mondialisme et finalement on se
raccroche à ce qu est le plus proche qui
est peut-être la région et c'est un
phénomène très intéressant et c'est la
question qu'il faut se poser c'est
comment articuler une véritable
subsidiarité c'est à dire comment on
peut articuler différemment différents
attachement attachement à l'europe un
attachement la nation à l'attachement à
la région centre ont bercé ni dans le
mult rhin centralisme jacobin qui nie
l'existence d'un thé régional ni dans un
régionalisme indépendantiste qui nie le
cas dans l'état nation qui reste
important pour la démocratie
c'est un phénomène que carl françois
hollande disait dans le livre de nos
confrères du monde doive est l'homme
qu'il craignait la craignait la
partition cc c'est une illustration de
d'un risque sur l'europe et peut-être
même schéma france bien sûr quand on
voyait avec la ligue du nord quand on
voyait qu'on a vu avec les cos est ce
que la dent mais mercredi puisque 10 au
génie c'est là où peuvent sera
finalement se réfugier les résidentes
oui mais au fond quand on donne la
parole au peuple
on se rend compte qu'ils ne partagent
pas non plus forcément le point de vue
de ces jeux le qualifie d' extrémistes
ce que je veux dire en écosse qui a eu
un référendum
est ce que c'est on dit non on reste
donc à l'espagne rose mais l'espagne
reste dans l'us le gouvernement espagnol
aurait dû les faire un référent des 70
parlementaires mais honni parlementaire
parce que il y en a 50 qui ont quitté la
salle
et de toute façon ils sont majoritaires
dans ce dans ce parlement la vraie
question c'est qui va reconnaître cette
indépendance parce que c'est vous pouvez
toujours proclamé les choses en droit
international et aussi la façon dont les
autres vous perçoivent donc là on a bien
vu l'union européenne ne la reconnaît
pas ce qu'elle dit c'est tf1
on attend de voir maintenant dans la
communauté internationale qui va
reconnaître c'est pour ça que c'est un
sujet entre légalité et légitimité dans
ce débat d'ailleurs marne à maroeuil
parle de l'égalité alors que plus de
demandes livre parle d'eux
j'ai dit mais ce qui est encore à voir
parce que pour le coup ça aurait pu
faire un dogme
il était non seulement illégal mais en
plus il n'y avait pas la participation
de tout le monde
un mode et sur l'église sur des réseaux
sur ce débat beaucoup d'internautes
prévoit de violence cette nuit en tout
cas qui vont venir au regard de ce qui
s'est déjà passé une dernière semaine et
au delà de ça aussi questionné sur la
police espagnole et spécialement en
catalogne qui serait apparemment assez
indépendantistes et comment est-ce
qu'elle va se comporter par rapport aux
événements qui risque d'arriver c'est
lui c'est peut-être l'une des clés de la
suite des événements on va continuer à
suivre ça on va quitter l'europe n'en va
rester en france
on va aller en guyane deuxième jour de
la visite des manuels macron et déjà une
polémique
on lui demandait de l'argent et voici sa
réponse je ne suis pas le père noël
parce que les guyanais sont pas des
enfants et donc je suis ici avec de
l'ambition pour les guyanes mais je suis
pas venu faire des promesses ce temps là
est fini
l'état a fait trop de promesses qui
n'ont pas été tenues donc je suis là
pour dire les choses en vérité telles
que je les vois prendre des engagements
que je saurai tenir durant mon
quinquennat est aussi assurée les
éléments d'autorité indispensable sur ce
territoire
martial oui oui la zone ardemment ce
n'est pas la première fois puisque la
raison pourquoi parce qu'il est
autoritaire si un jour il ya ou bien il
a raison sur le fond mais sur le fond on
peut pas continuer à déverser comme ça
des milliards sur des collectivités ces
sortes de puits sans fond on voit bien
la dernière fois qu il
comme ça une explosion en guyane c'était
chaud hollande ils ont déversé des
milliards pour calmer bon on voit bien
que ça ne résout rien même si évidemment
ce n'est pas encore on rappelle
d'ailleurs l'impact mais la référence
est une référence donc ils parlaient
également d'un plan qui a été voté qui a
été engagée à la suite d'un conflit
social très dur qui a eu lieu au
printemps en guyane une grève doublé
d'un certain nombre de soucis sur le sur
la sécurité et l'immigration illégale et
le gouvernement de bernard cazeneuve
avait promis un milliard d'euros plus un
engagement à 2 milliards d'euros
d'ailleurs question subsidiaire à ce qui
s'est fait avoir macron par les
engagements de hollande en la matière on
est toujours lié par les engagements des
autres on l'a vu sur le budget
la difficulté physique nouvelle
illustrée en tout cas sur la sécurité
ils l'assument puisqu'il va accélérer
les choses et je crois que c'est ça
c'est plutôt bien aussi
ce qui est amusant c'est que tout le
monde a retenu la comparaison avec le
père noël
c'est pas la première fois que mm à
craon utilisent cette image là alors
apparemment tout à l'heure tu sais pas
vraiment non c'est sa façon de
s'exprimer il l'avait déjà dit à la
réunion il avait dit devant eux les
world paul et gm est cependant pendant
la campagne donc c'est vraiment une
image qu'il est mieux utiliser en disant
je ne viens pas avec des cadeaux je ne
suis pas il pourrait dire le porte
monnaie pour pour déverser de l'argent
c'est plutôt bien s'est compliqué
politiquement parce que derrière il faut
assumer
faut assumer les erreurs qui a eu dans
la nuit mais dans ce langage là en tout
cas quand il l'a tenue war le pôle gms
ça a créé des perturbations
immédiatement mais après dans la dans la
continuité ça paye au génie langage de
fermeté
oui mais moi je trouve que j'en ai un
peu assez qu'on compare et ex la moindre
petite phrase pour en faire un dérapage
il ya une parole
on peut contester le fond de ski 10 ans
quand je suis là car je pense qu'il a
raison de tenir ce qui est dit après que
la forme tournante estime que choquer
maintenant dès qu'on passe rarement vous
accessoires d'accord slam longueur
d'onde avec karl sur l'europe
dans macron il ya vraiment il ya
vraiment oui peut-être les ya vraiment
une révolution politique comme le dit
souvent à des confrères alexandre devait
on peut s'interroger sur
le nom je venais tous des fachos quand
le vocabulaire je comprends que c'est un
dérapage c'est ridicule de qualifier
d'autres dérapages des combes sort un
peu des coûts
ok pour la forme sur le fond le fond je
suis d'accord et que la lentille dit il
faut arrêter de faire des cadeaux et
déverser de l'argent sans contrôle et
sans efficacité sur des collectivités
territoriales mais bon j'ai l'impression
que même que pour d'autres catégories de
la population malienne macron peut
servir à voir l'image d'un père noël
c'est notamment pour les plus riches à
qui il a offert généreusement une
suppression de l isf
donc il sait faire des cadeaux aussi
donc c'est un père noël alternative à
géométrie variable était la plus reprise
puisque je sais pas si on peut parler de
dérapage mais forcément comme le
permettent ça parle à tout le monde ça a
été bien repris que les guyanais au
moyen aimer le la comparaison avec le
fait que c'était pas des enfants
oui mais voilà il ya quand même un petit
côté bon maison qu'ils ont compris a
versé que il le fait d'employer le mot
enfant ils ont pensé que avoir cédé
réclament comme tel y avait un doute y
avait doute mais on va dire que bon
c'est une question de formulation en
revanche comme comme vous disiez la
formulation elle a permis de faire une
chose c'est que c'était beaucoup
reprises par les opposants c'était une
expression qui était c'est le père noël
des riches et le père fouettard de la
guyane française et ce à sa reprise que
d'abord c'est une formule choc sa marque
perd sur les réseaux ça marche toujours
bien et puis finalement si on prend des
des symboliques aussi forte que le père
noël bat forcément on regarde ça qu
apporte comme cadeaux le père noël et le
père mais lille n'a plus tous fait des
cadeaux pour l'opposition et la france a
soumise au riz jean baptiste sergeant
justement comment vit cette polémique
sur sur les réseaux et sur sur twitter
c'est en tous les cas ces derniers ces
dernières heures
il faut dire quand même que les phrases
chocs que ça fonctionne quand même sacré
le débat donc ce père noël a bien
fonctionné depuis s'était déclaré que ça
a été un des sujets le hashtag guyane a
été un des sujets les plus traités
rentes
huit mille messages depuis ce matin je
suis du coup j'ai un petit peu regardé
sur twitter ce qu'on pouvait
identifié comme militant titre et comme
revendication alors j'ai d'abord trouvé
pierre qui dit dommage que ce soit les
vacances il ironise un petit peu
emmanuel macron ne pourra pas visiter
nos belles écoles qui tombent en ruine
quand même une critique en terme de
budget de moyens un peu plus loin sans
souci elle ajoute cette france
européenne d'amazonie ne doit pas être
une base spatiale est un puits d'or
l'humain avant tout ça c'est ce qui
revient en disant que c'est un des
départements les plus riches de france
pourtant qui a le moins de dotations
armand s'en prend directement emmanuel
macron lui en dénonçant unilatéralement
l'accord mâcon déclare la guerre aux
peuples guyanais
donc là on est un peu plus sur les
violences des nuit dernière notamment
diogène dans l'autre sens enfin on
refuse de parler à des voyous cagoulés
nous attendons des paroles fortes depuis
février effectivement des dernières
événements qui sont passés en guyane et
enfin tel regard des violences des 1000
dernières ironise finalement nous
l'avons nous l'avons notre égalité les
guyanais sont traités comme des
manifestants de l'hexagone c'était
également une allusion aux mouvements là
des 500 qui s'était qu'on en avait vu
pendant le printemps deux personnes
cagoulées mais qui s'opposaient à
l'insécurité
hugo nous dit sur facebook macron
n'assume pas des cadeaux qui l'a fait
lorsqu'il était auprès de hollande quand
il a fallu gagner des voix en outre mer
il assumer les engagements de son
prédécesseur aujourd'hui il oublie nos
compatriotes
ça c'est un reproche que macron va va
subir pendant plusieurs années parce
qu'il est juste ou pas est juste il
n'était plus au gouvernement en avril
dernier ils étaient partis déjà depuis
un moment il était en campagne un port
pour vous ça le dédouane pas non plus
des cinq années moi je rappelle toujours
il a inspiré le programme de françois
hollande
il n'était pas le seul mais il était en
charge du cercle des économistes
donc quand même sur un point essentiel
ensuite il était secrétaire général
adjoint chargé de l'économie à l'elysée
ce qui est quand même un des rôles
fondamentaux
et puis il ya une petite parenthèse et
il est devenu ministre de l'économie
donc il peut pas se dédouaner de tous en
l'occurrence l'as sur la guyane au
moment où le plan a été mis en route en
avril pour le coup il n'était pas le
génie albert ne pensent pas comme vous
il dit le président vaincrons
manque de subtilité dans son langage
subtilisé une dirai peut-être de
délicatesse mais mais après je pense que
c'est aussi important de savoir on est
comme une langue politique extrêmement
police et on appelle ça la langue de
bois
et moi je trouve que c'est parfois
rafraîchissante d'avoir des hommes
politiques qui disent les choses
franchement
quitte à en effet heurté certaines
sensibilités on est vraiment dans un
on aime ça c'est un autre sujet mais on
est vraiment une police du langage de
plus en plus de plus en plus prégnante
il faut faire attention à chaque mot
qu'on utilise pour ne pas vexer telle ou
telle catégorie de la population et on
prend on perd la vertu comment dire
corrosif du langage qui est aussi là
pour orthez pour et pourraient pousser à
réfléchir et pas seulement pour ménager
on rappelle donc que un plan d'urgence
d'un milliard d'euros après plusieurs
semaines de grèves et de manifestations
contre l'insécurité l'immigration
illégale avait été adoptée donc en avril
dernier et ce plan là emmanuel macron a
dit qu'il qui le mettrait à exécution
l'autre engagement qui a été pris par le
gouvernement de bernard cazeneuve
c'était d'avoir pris acte je cite d'une
demande de 2 milliards d'euros 2
milliards 1 également et exactement
hélas pour l'instant c'est là où il ya
une des polémiques il ya des accords là
enfin de la part d' emmanuel macron la
présence juste une question génie de la
présence de jean claude juncker aux
côtés de macron c'est une bonne chose
en guyane où c'est une mise sous tutelle
de l'europe
moi je pense que tel par leur offre je
sais pas trop ce qui vient faire
là dedans et c'est vrai que ça me
dérange un peu de bruit de
d'accompagnement de tutelle comme si on
était co dirigé par deux dirigeants ont
eu un dirigeant qu'on n'a pas du tout
élu es et qui n'a pas du tout été choisi
par le peuple français donc oui ça me ça
me dérange car ça dépend aussi de l'
influence réelle de juncker souvient que
nicolas sarkozy en est aussi barroso un
peu partout dans ses déplacements
c'est plus une manière de deux les
contraintes en disant voilà vous étiez
là vous avez devenu donc maintenant il
faut continuer à suivre
et c'est de rappeler que la france un
rayonnement mondial peut être aussi on
va quitter macron rester avec nous on va
s'intéresser à un moment à celui qui
voudrait être son opposant laurent
wauquiez est il une menace pour la
droite et mais est-ce qu'il sera surtout
à la droite ce que le roundup et aux
jardiniers aux agriculteurs une drogue
un peu dangereuse réponse dans un
instant mais avant justement va
s'intéresser au glyphosate faut-il
l'interdire
et bien la réponse est sans appel c'est
oui à 80 1% selon le sondage
hebdomadaire doxa dentsu pour le figaro
et france info véronique reis hoult
personne ne trouve grâce aux personnes
ne trouvent d'intérêt aux produits
monsanto en tout cas dans le nom de
sondages a parlé 19%
d'internautes mais quand même là secret
à senna si c'est pas les produits de
monsanto particulièrement celles
glyphosate a été produit par monsanto
mais après oui oui c'est même si quand
on regarde dans des explications et ils
comprennent que c'est utile que c'était
pour les agriculteurs mais c'est un
sujet qui ne fait pas débat que 80 % des
français interrogés considèrent qu' il
faut arrêter voilà c'est un sujet qui
n'est pas qu'ils m'aiment pas un sujet
de polémique et en plus ce quelles que
soient les convictions partisanes que
l'on soit écolo qu'on soit de droite
qu'on soit de gauche peu importe tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire que le
glyphosate n'est pas un produit qui doit
être maintenu après il ya d'autres
sujets dans ce sondage qui sont plus
vraiment mener mais sur celui là et
c'est pas un débat pas plus d'un sondage
que sur le web une globale mans tout le
monde est d'accord pour dire que il faut
pas faut pas continuer le génie
j'imagine que ça doit vous réjouir ce
genre de résultats de sondages louis
pour une fois je ne suis plus un
consensus
cette question des sondages non mais
c'est vrai que ça me paraît
tout à fait logique et normal
d'interdire ce produit qui a été reconnu
par plusieurs institutions comme
probable quand c'est cancérigène est
validée et commencez pas prouver le
caractère cancérigène mais ça l'a prouvé
mais ya quand même certaines nombreuses
études qui montrent une corrélation et
je te signale juste qu'on a inscrit le
principe de précaution dans la
constitution qui estiment probablement
que la charge de la preuve est un état
incomber à celui qui me prouver que que
c'était pas quand il n'est pas au point
n'est pas dangereux donc à charge la
preuve revient à monsanto nous prouver
que c'est pas c'est pas dangereux et non
pas à autorités sanitaires a prouvé
qu'il est dangereux première première
chose et là on a vraiment en effet une
un combat entre la démocratie et
l'opinion majoritaire et les lobbys qui
sont même très très actif notamment au
sein de l'union européenne on a vu
d'ailleurs révélé que le les médias ont
révélé que l'union européenne dans un de
ses rapports avec copier coller un
rapport de monsanto de 2012 nous
rapporte attendre 2015
des centaines de pages a été carrément
copiés collés pour pour justifier
l'utilisation du
du glyphosate et je pense que voilà
c'est très pratique et qu' il faut faire
très attention on a vraiment des lobbys
très très actif c'est quand même des
milliards et des milliards d'euros de
produits chimiques qui sont vendus
chaque année et donc il ya des intérêts
financiers in ans donc on peut pas faire
comme s'il y avait deux opinions qu'ils
affrontaient de manière avec des armes
égales
il ya vraiment des enjeux financiers
très fort d'un côté alors je vais vous
donner la parole mais je voudrais quand
même qu'on donne la parole à notre
confrère avec de la chaîne et il suit
les questions agricoles à au figaro et
qui ne partage pas votre avis eugénie
qui a réagi c'est 80% ce sondage
et il répond à focus de darian le coeur
en voici un extrait c'est 80 % disent
que ils admettent avoir deux à faible
niveau de connaissances sur ce sujet
mach les invite à avoir les avis de
l'agencé d'aller dans le fond des avis
des agences européennes lagence des
produits chimiques echa est aussi l'
agence de sécurité des aliments efsa qui
elles n'ont pas dit que c'était un
produit cancérigène
je vous rappelle aussi que la caféine
est probablement cancérigènes oxydes de
fer et probablement cancérigène donc il
y aurait beaucoup d'autres produits
qu'il faudrait retirer je pense que le
débat il est très émotionnel il est plus
dans l'émotion que dans le dans le
scientifique ou dans le rationnel on
retrouve le vaincu sa juste après cette
émission mais c'est pas tant dans
l'émotionnel d'abord c'est pas que ce
qu'ils reprochent la raison des 80%
c'est pas que pour des raisons de cancer
et jamin c'est aussi des sujets sur
l'environnement beaucoup sur des
abeilles alors vous rappelle quand même
que justin le glyphosate est un
herbicide développé par monsanto on l'a
retrouvé dans de la nourriture des pâtes
des légumes et donc il est accusé d'être
probablement potentiellement
cancérigènes le problème c'est que il
est très utilisé par les agriculteurs
ils y tiennent et sa suppression
pourrait coûter 2 milliards d'euros à la
filière en fait le sujet d'accords dans
le souhaitait demander aux gens ce
qu'ils en pensaient mais après il y
avait un sujet qui est d'abord sais pas
ils sont pas les 80 % ces paliers
simplement fait que c'est cancérigène
parce qu'effectivement c'est pas prouvé
il ya un sujet de suspicion ne s'est pas
que ça
et après on voit bien là pour le coup
c'est sur les forums plutôt qu'on arrive
à le voir que dans le sondage qui est
ils sont conscients que c'est compliqué
de le retirer et sont conscients que
pour les agriculteurs c'est compliqué
ils n'ont pas envie de me montrer du
doigt les agriculteurs donc le sujet et
des plus d'accompagner ce départ mais
c'est pas c'est pas un sujet de yala
produits horrible qui entraîne tuer tout
le monde c'est un sujet de prendre
conscience de donc et après ils sont
beaucoup plus renseigné qu'il ne le
croit parce que les gens vont sur les
blogs sur les forums
il ya des blocs qui sont très très bien
renseignés qui donnent des informations
assez clair et qui mettant en avant les
contradictions sur le sujet donc non
globalement les français sont plutôt
bien renseigné plutôt raisonnable en
césar qu'on peut pas le faire du jour au
lendemain aucune envie de stigmatiser
les agriculteurs
une petite envie quand même de
stigmatiser l'europe régulièrement et là
c'est un petit coup sur l'europe en ce
moment ça serait quand même bien que les
mecs tas de fumer ça c'est s'est
retrouvé dans les questions ou dans les
questions bien sûr sous les forces et
mans il ya un énervement l'attend sur ce
sujet dès qu'on parle du kif lausanne
effectivement il ya une mobilisation il
ya eu des pétitions qui ont été en
séries en plus les abeilles c'est un
sujet qui touche beaucoup nous on peut
le voir au figaro.fr c'est un des sujets
qui le plus lu c'est quand on parle les
avait quelque chose vraiment qui est qui
réveille les passions françaises et
effectivement quand vous parlez de
l'europe une fois de plus on retrouve un
peu une décision out of the brain ne
sais pas pourquoi c'est là et qui va
m'en va a scandé ce camp est scandalisé
des internautes ils se mobilisent c'est
la preuve d'une mobilisation est
possible par la masse connectés cette
mise en cause de l'europe car ça le trop
justifié justifiée parce qu on al
impression qu effectivement elle ne fait
rien ce qui me frappe maintenant dans le
sondage c'est surtout de voir que
monsanto a dépensé j'imagine des
milliards pour faire du lobbying qu'il a
été efficace plus ou moins sur les
institutions mais qu auprès des français
ou des opinions publiques
c'est raté parce que là pour le coup
s'il ya 80% des personnes interrogées
qui réagissent comme ça c'est que une
partie du lobbying a raté et que les
gens ont cette impression là que ces
voiliers
alors qu'internet est sûre en tout cas
ça n'a pas convaincu effectivement franc
qui nous dit sur sur facebook entre
essayer vide de vivre longtemps et
garder 2 milliards le choix est vite
fait al'inverse hugo lui répond écoutons
déjà des agriculteurs qui connaissent
mieux que nous la réalité du mil du
métier hulot est sous la pression des
écolos et va finir par tuer nos
agriculteurs comprendre c'est que
monsanto et tous ces produits chimiques
c'est la corde avec laquelle la rupture
français s'est levé d'un français se
sont pendus c'est à dire que le lay du
tueur ultra productiviste qui c'était un
choix qui a été fait dans les années
50-60 a tué l'agriculture française
c'est à dire que qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
on n'a plus que 3 % des buts en france
c'est c'est un choix que c'était qui a
été fait qui fait qu'on a des liens des
domaines gigantesque qui sont gérés en
effet avec de manière ultra
productiviste avec des produits
chimiques mais il ya d'autres choses qui
sont deux sociétés qui sont possibles et
qu'ils peuvent faire vivre la culture y
avait un article très intéressant dans
le canard enchaîné cette semaine qui
montrait que les une expérimentation qui
a été mené dans les deux sèvres où on a
justement pris 4 150 agriculteurs on
l'aura ils ont cessé d'utiliser des
produits chimiques sur 45 milles
hectares il ya une baisse de rendement
3 à 5% en effet donc moindre rendement
mais en fait ils économisent est
tellement en produits chimiques quand
finalement ici retrouvez donc on voit
qu'il ya aussi une dépense énorme et des
agriculteurs en produits chimiques qui
peut être compensée par autre chose il
faut trouver un nouveau modèle
économique mais si on n'interdit pas un
moment par un geste fort par la loi on
ne pourra jamais trouvé l'alternative
on fera une émission consacrée à ce
sujet je vous le promets les deux savent
qu'ils ont été un département qui est
touchée également par le remembrement
un autre sondage que vous avez fait qui
a été fait cette semaine donc parrot
doxa et dentsu il porte sur le ceta les
chiffres vont vous plaire également
eugénie puisque 64% des français pensent
que c'est une mauvaise chose
cocorico c'est que pour le coup là c'est
un sondage qui sera peu suivie d'effets
puisque pendant moi même si ma croix
fait certaines annonces on voit pas
comment
ce
ce traité va être remis en cause donc
voilà encore une fois les peuples n'ont
pas été consultés et c'est pour beaucoup
une défaite de l'opinion majoritaire
véronique après il faut faut savoir que
ça c'est les résultats donc sur
l'ensemble des français mais autant tout
à l'heure il n'y avait pas de clivage
politique là il ya quand même quelques
petits clivages politiques quand vous
regardez les
qui sont les oiseaux posées aux états et
c'est plutôt à droite
plus tôt les militants et sympathisants
de droite
évidemment les militants et
sympathisants écolos et est plutôt
apparentés ps ont pu remonter sur de
settat là où certains secteurs des
manuels macron je voudrais pas dire
d'adri parce que j'ai pu les chiffres en
tête mais c'était à peu près révéla
parts à peu près même niveau que le
global mais par contre ce qui était
intéressant c'était de regarder ce que
ils mettaient derrière c'est un parce
qu'en fait la connaissance du sujet
c'est à les écolos ne connaissent très
bien
c'est pas forcément le cas des autres
donc ils ont répondu on leur posait la
question dans le dans le sondage ils
connaissaient mais on n'en demandait pas
ce que c'était et il ya sans doute un
amalgame qui est fait derrière le ceta
plus fortement encore que sur le sujet
dont on parlait tout à l'heure du
glyphosate il yal'autre sondages car les
là j'aimerais bien avoir votre réaction
55% des français pensent que l'action de
nicolas hulot ne pèse pas fortement pour
défendre l'environnement
véronique va nuancer ce que je veux dire
mais déjà vous car qu'est-ce que ça à
penser quand vous voyez ces chiffres ça
montre que nicolas on attend c'est
injuste ou pas non non non c'est injuste
parce que on attend les résultats
concrets de la la présence de nicolas
hulot au gouvernement pour l'instant il
a engagé un certain nombre de choses il
a dit des choses mais on n'a pas en
faisant dire ça je pense que c'est ça ce
que ça veut dire c'est à dire que mon
papa du coup de patte personnelle voilà
pour l'instant on voit pas encore
exactement la patte de vélo on le verra
peut-être au moment en décembre voilà
exactement on comptera la décision sur
la trame des landes est la conséquence
que lui en tirera alors justement le
sondage d'ailleurs revient sur cette
dame des landes
c'étaient les trois sujets qui
ressortait à notre dame des landes c'est
un français sur deux jusque que nicolas
hulot devrait démissionner si la
décision de construction de notre dame
de l'an
et était finalement présent en décembre
c'est exactement ce qu'il a dit donc ils
sont d'accord d'android la diffusera le
faire après globalement c'est d'accord
avec vous le le sondage et puis on voit
bien qu'on est les gens s'expriment
c'est plus que est une espèce de perte
de confiance et une baisse un peu de
popularité de nicolas hulot mais pas de
temps parce qu'il n'a rien fait parce
que globalement à ce stade là voilà
c'est plus que cette patte personnelle
que chacun attendait comme c'était dans
les ministres les pilules les plus
connus les plus attendus les plus
populaires lui et et madame flessel et
tele2 qui avait quand même soulevé plus
d' enthousiasme que de questions mais en
fait les gens se disent bon ok en fait
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait de si spécial
pour le moment en quoi il a apporté
quelque chose de différent
donc c'est ça mais on n'est pas encore
du tout dans un rejet un début de perte
de confiance
il serait temps surtout que les éléments
dont on a parlé sur nicolas hulot il ya
quinze jours trois semaines c'était des
hésitations sur des états d'âme
est-ce qu'il est bien ce qui va pas
démissionner ou pas alors qu'ils
n'avaient pas encore d'éléments concrets
sur
il a été mis en minorité où il n'est pas
majoritaire sur sur des éléments où il
n'a pas pesé
donc les gens n'étaient pas compris ce
qui la suivait glyphosate j'y reviens
mais comme il y avait un sujet la
commission européenne là il va être
attendu là parce que ça va être un
premier pour un peu concret d'une
fondation est très impliquée sur ces
sujets et prendre la parole un virement
pour fustiger alors j'essaie justement
parce que ça fait partie des sujets
qu'on va continuer à suivre les vous
restez avec nous revient après cette
émission justement sur le glyphosate
vous ne serez peut-être pas convaincu
mais vous deviendrez incollable grâce
aux questions lumineuse d'ariane le
coeur et aux réponses éclairantes eric
de la chesnais en attendant place à
l'actualité qui se déroule actuellement
entre barcelone et madrid et dans le
monde puisqu'il des réactions un peu
partout berlin dit qu'elle ne
reconnaîtra pas l'indépendance de la
catalogne
mariano rajoy a tout mon soutien c'est
ce que vient de déclarer emmanuel
matthew mc rond en attendant laurent
wauquiez est il une menace pour la
droite c'est pas marine le pen qui parle
c'est le trait juppéiste maël de calan
candidat à la présidence de l air voici
sa thèse elle mérite d'être écouté
on s'est peut-être élire à l'occasion
d'une élection interne on le verra en
décembre prochain
mais on se rend inéligibles aux
élections nationales moi je crains que
laurent wauquiez soit le benoît hamon de
la droite dire très populaire auprès des
adhérents qui qui qui incarne une droite
qui se referme qui se rétrécit autour
d'un coeur d'adhérents d'un coeur de
doctrine la carte d'électeur de plus en
plus restreint à la fin on fait 7% dans
les urnes et on a cinquante députés
ça n'est pas ce que je souhaite pour la
droite eugénie vous avez forcément un
avis
le problème principal de laurent
wauquiez c'est laurent wauquiez qui
avait un problème une personnalité qui
fait qu'il était extrêmement rejeté
l'intervention camps ce qui n'a pas su
créer des affinités et qu on n a pas su
créer un clan congrès des gens qui le
soutiennent et c'est vrai que ce qui est
frappant dans cette semaine c'est à quel
point
il crée énormément de d'animosité à
l'intérieur même de sa famille politique
je pense que c'est plus là le problème
qu'un problème de ligne et de fou parce
qu'il a mon avis
il ya quand même des limites et dangers
chez les républicains sur la nécessité
de de revenir aux fondamentaux notamment
sur la question des sexualités de
l'immigration et puis aussi d'aller au
peuple puisque c'est vraiment l'enjeu
est d'ailleurs le seul créneau
électorale qui s'offre à la droite c'est
d'ailleurs au peuple d'aller vers les
classes populaires qui qui est d'aller
rechercher les gens qui avaient voté
front national
donc j'aurais tendance à dire que voilà
le problème est plus en plus à la
personnalité de laurent wauquiez qu'un
véritable clivage de fonds l'union
européenne n'a pas besoin d'autres
fissures c'est ce que vient de déclarer
jean claude juncker à propos de un gros
pot de la catalogne
vous prendrez votre réaction véronique
sur justement cette histoire ça aussi
c'est la personnalité la ligne de
laurent wauquiez
je voulais demander à carla van est ce
que vous croyez sérieusement que ce
genre de discours de la part de mal de
calan ça passe à droite
ah non pas du tout alors sur le fond il
pose une vraie question
le problème c'est que sur la forme on
évoquait ce que 10 ml macron dans le
père noël à dire c'est le amende droite
voilà c'est très bien ça va faire le
buzz mais ça va ça fait pas avancer les
choses donc c'est un peu dommage de
régler sur le fond
non parce que voilà ce que je vous dis
c'est que derrière il pose une vraie
question de fond est ce que la ligne qui
va être adoptée la en décembre par
laurent wauquiez et c'est une ligne qui
entraîne la droite à redevenir
majoritaire c'est une réaction non on
n'en sait rien pour le coup il va
falloir attendre les élections
ce qui est sûr en revanche c'est que
pour l'instant laurent wauquiez dans une
campagne il s'adresse à des militants et
donc il fait un certain discours on l'a
entendu à mandelieu mais la vraie
question c'est ça va une fois qu'il sera
élu il ya quand même assez peu de tout
qu'est ce qu'il va faire quel est le
programme quel est le projet qui a
adopté ou qu'il va travailler et c'est
là où c'est intéressant parce que quand
on l'interrogeait là dessus il dit des
choses il dit oui notamment eu par
exemple sur l'écologie il faut
retravailler l'écologie et créer une
sorte d'écologie de droite qui serait
pas une écologie punitive comme les
écolos disant il faut une taxe il faut
ça non réfléchira
ad comment le progrès peut interagir sur
l'écologie ça c'est intéressant
pareil sur les classes populaires
effectivement comment faire revenir les
classes populaires
voilà ça c'est un vrai travail et c'est
là dessus je pense qu'il faudra juger
laurent wauquiez plus que sur celle de
l'amour sa personne sa personnalité crée
des doutes
c'est une idée qu'on retrouve ces ondes
et qu'on retrouve mais déjà je trouve
que c'est important de rappeler que la
popularité c'est pas la même chose que
la notoriété et dans le cas de monsieur
wauquiez on a un sujet de notoriété face
aux autres leaders rappelle que vous
êtes une spécialiste des réseaux sociaux
l'influent non mais c'est pas la même
chose donc aujourd'hui on a aussi une
réalité pour les militants il ya un
candidat
les autres ils ne connaissent pas bien
donc on parle forcément lui et donc il a
de la notoriété n'est pas populaire il a
forcément populaire après il faut se
dire que c'est comme vous le disiez une
élection militants quand on regarde ce
que disent les militants parce que là
c'est l'un des intérêts des du web c'est
qu'on va regarder donc ce que disent des
des populations bien spécifique voire
même ceux qui sont non seulement midi
tanger et qu'ils disent dans leur bio
j'ai payé ma cotisation et globalement
ils sont assez perdu 1 il trouve que ils
ont le mot qui sort le plus c'est
ridicule et honte en lisant cette
histoire déconstructive la honte et
derrière ils disent on sait pas enfin
voila il
ils critiquent pas tellement wauquiez
mais ils ne soutiennent pas non plus
plus que ça le sujet je comprends qu'ils
n'y comprennent rien à regarder écouter
ce que disait laurent wauquiez à propos
dé constructif il n'avait pas de mots
assez durs hier soir écouter et comme le
disait chirac un chef c'est fait pour
ces faits et ce foutoir généralisée dans
lequel on est en ce moment
croyez-moi si jamais je m'occupe de la
famille des républicains c'est fini on
va y remettre de l'ordre et ses espèces
de guignol qui tout en nous ayant trahi
continue à donner des leçons avec un
cynisme insupportable
les constructif c'est dehors dehors
donc les constructif c'est dehors ça
c'est laurent le nouveau pied et voilà
comment se définit le directeur de
campagne de laurent wauquiez geoffroy
didier les constructif dans l'âme et
j'ai pas attendu que thierry solère créé
le groupe les constructif pour être
constructif
je pense que nous sommes tous
constructif mais avec un petit c est pas
avec un c majuscule de jany j'avais fait
un pari c'était que ça vous concerne et
apparemment c'est grâce à mon sens c'est
vrai c'est sait même pas intéressant
quoi c'est vraiment on dirait des jeux
c'est pas une mais des crapauds qui c
est qui se maquille cd qui se discutent
les morceaux du vieux monde
moi je pense que de dire j'ai ma
conviction profonde c'est que les
républicains est tabassé un astre mort
comme le parti socialiste était un astre
mort sur françois hollande et qui a fini
par exploser et que les américains
finiront par disparaître parce que ce
n'est pas possible de tenir ainsi c'est
un parti terminé et je pense que ça
continue encore à tourner mais cliquer
en font au fin fond est fini et je
trouve que cet extrait il est à l'image
ça c'est de la pure comme mais en
sémantique pour qualifier des gens
qu'ils veulent sortir les utilise le mot
constructif depuis le début c'est quand
même bizarre de sortir des gens
constructif donc du coup on voit bien le
porte-parole it i am et je suis
constructif avec un petit s'est fait une
espèce de truc est hyper bizarre c'est
il aurait fallu aussi sévèrement que de
la com et qui trouva mots qui ne soit
pas dans le positif voulait sortir des
gens qui a utilisé un mot pour les
qualifiés qui est positif c'est cette
étrange il nous reste peu de temps mais
quand même je voudrais résister à cet
assaut requiem de de génie et posé une
question de fond car qu'on a déjà eu ici
même c est ce que finalement le problème
c'est que laurent wauquiez il fait une
campagne très à droite mais au fond il
n'est pas si à droite c'est là aussi il
ya peut-être un manant ce match et bien
il fait de la politique je fais pour
dire cette formule alors je pose la
question différemment on va sortir des
communes laurent wauquiez à une
rhétorique très droitière tr/mn si on
veut
mais il est quand même il a geoffroy
didier comme directeur de campagne il a
appris le soutien de virginie calmels
qui a soutenu alain juppé on le rappelle
c'est lui faire un mauvais procès comme
le disait alexis brézet fière de dire
aussi à droite laurent wauquiez que mal
en pis ses adversaires il ya deux choses
1 vous pouvez pas reprocher à quelqu'un
qui fait une campagne pour la présidence
d'un parti de déjà penser à un
rassemblement
vous présidez pas juste sur votre
schéma de pensée non les républicains
faut le rappeler à l'origine c'est le
successeur de l'ump l'ump a été créée
pour rassembler les gaullistes les
libéraux et les centristes même si une
grande partie en lan quitté depuis
donc vous vous pouvez pas alors que vous
allez être le chef commencé par dire je
vire tous les autres et ça se fait sur
ma ligne ça va se faire sur sa ligne
mais avec la pluie geoffroy didier et
les autres donc ça c'est fondamental
il a toujours dit d'ailleurs qu'il
allait qui voulaient aller qu'il voulait
rassembler jusqu'à jusqu'à quand même en
allant un peu plus loin à droite mais
mais je crois qu'il ya vraiment ce qu'on
peut dire aussi ce qu'il ya une une
hyper diabolisation de laurent wauquiez
et on a l'impression qu'il s'entoure de
centristes comme comme c'est un peu ses
gousses d'ail pour éloigner les vampires
mais ça ne marche pas et parce qu'il est
diabolisé un par un et c'est vrai que
c'est un phénomène médiatique assez
intéressant à l'hyper diabolisation de
bangkok et comme si le finalement le la
disparition de marine le pen du paysage
médiatique nécessité la création d'un
nouveau diable médiatique et c'est le
rôle que tient laurent wauquiez
aujourd'hui c'est à dire le rôle
d'épouvantail
2 du fait du fâché du crypto fasciste en
puissance qui commet une open a disparu
et bien avant wauquiez devient et c'est
assez fascinant de voir que le système
et des tic a besoin de générer un diable
a résisté avec un procès d'intention
près avec 1% systématiquement reproche a
alors invoqué la possibilité de faire un
accord avec le front national
quand bien même il est dit il répète
mais depuis plusieurs mois en tout cas
depuis la campagne il l'écrit dans le
figaro ailleurs je ne ferai jamais
d'accord et si quelqu'un fait un accord
il est gris et bas ça ça n'est pas
entendue c'est vraiment très curieux et
au grand dam de nicolas dupont aignan e
jean baptiste
à midi nous avions tiré solaire au talk
et effectivement il y avait ce côté
boucs émissaires de à gauche on dit
c'est voilà il ya la droite est en train
d'exploser on se moque et à droite on
dit c'est un missile de macron donc en
fait y'a rien à faire et tout se
disloque et là j'ai un commentaire du
gros cube y parle plus du terrain qu'ils
aient dit wauquiez la seule solution
pour la droite
regardez un nouvel rhône alpes les
résultats pourquoi personne n'en parle
il est pragmatique et c'est du sérieux
il ya un côté il a quand même un côté
positif il avait même une base plus
peut-être sur le terrain sachant qu'en
plus on ne juge pas y avoir un système
médiatique qui gouverne avec le modem
oui pour quelqu'un qui est crypto
d'extrême orient du coup vos qui aura
été centriste avec ingeus et eugénie
bastié aura fait fans finalement en
creux une éloge d'halloween parce
qu'elle a fait un requiem pour les
républicains à la parler de vampires
également des devantures pour laurent
wauquiez et de diable pour marine le pen
j'ai pensé mais on est là pour apprendre
des choses et avoir des points de vue
merci beaucoup merci de nous avoir
suivis vous avez rendez vous tout de
suite avec ariane le coeur et eric de la
chesnais pour en savoir plus et vous
allez en savoir plus sur le glyphosate
nous on se retrouve lundi
bon week-end sur fion live
[Musique]